Riley your grandfather is Elvis none
other than Elvis
[Applause]
I thought I'd wait for the Drew
Barrymore show to drop out I I've been a
long time fan of yours and I've watched
everything you've ever been in that's a
crazy thing coming from you I just thank
you I was astonished what did you did
you have to do to develop a voice like
this out of were you a singer before no
I mean well Sam and I were the only two
here actually or in the band anyway that
had no experience singing so both of us
really started out
um not great
all the more impressive when you see the
show because it's it's phenomenal your
voice is magnanimous I love it so much
we did use the musical theater I did and
you've contemplated doing some musicals
Les Mis cats something in the air my
experience with musical auditions have
never has never gone great
um but no I I think that when you see
this I auditioned for cats the the
musical phenomenon that was cats the
movie um yeah
let me just tell you the dark The Dance
Part of That audition was was something
to behold uh because I think I think I
remember sounding in like a waiting room
and all the guys and girls that were in
there were all ballet dancers and of
course I'd never had any ballet training
before so what did you do well they they
tried to teach me ballet within a minute
and a half yeah
[Applause]
so I thought oh I'm gonna be a cat I'm
gonna be a cat you know like you know
the whole camera you know but no there
was there was none of that there was
basically a guy who was in this the
audience huge stage and this guy came
out the audience was like let me let me
let me teach you let me teach you the
dance so that you know five six seven
[Music]
I was like
[Applause]
yeah the first move is it a left foot or
right foot I mean that was I couldn't do
it it was bad it was bad all right
Camilla you're an LA girl yes I am too
raised I mean that's why I haven't
buried I like to say oh very good well
not too soon how did you escape like the
valley girl accent I'm stuck with this
thing for life well like I could do it I
did go to school in the valley but I've
just like tried uh to to just neutralize
it for I mean auditioning and stuff and
California is like the most neutral
accent I didn't know like I don't know
if I'm stuck with this thing forever I
mean you just said it was forever like
forever
now I hear it I hear it I hear it I hear
it the way that you guys love music in
the show I mean Josh you're like in a
real band in your real life like how did
the Music Experience like help you it
really helped I mean I felt like in
having sort of spent a lot of my life
playing music and doing gigs that a lot
of my uh sort of backstory was kind of
done for me and I felt like I'd lived it
I love music I've Loved music my whole
life I've been music adjacent but man I
suck at it like I just don't have that
gift
um tsuki is it true that um you and
someone up here became best friends like
besties through filming this uh are we
are we I mean I become besties with
everyone really is there a particular
question Riley and some Sebastian of
course
[Laughter]
what was it was there like a moment or
was it because you do build families yes
you know she just never stopped pooling
me she just called me all the time
and she's come and stayed at my house
and and uh and yeah and just comes
around all the time and I know we we
love each other
[Laughter]
and I think actually we you know we I
fell in love with I actually fell in
love with every you just fall in love
with everyone when you watch them
perform as well that's all we have I
mean we are a family yeah here this is
what I love that I love that
and if you play the drums but you're
also a salsa dancer
uh like I
like that Rhythm City
like like a little bit of that you know
and then and then here we are yeah
I'm like
thank you I was like I mean it was very
good the worst shoes for this I think I
might I might have you at a similar
level I actually do like our shoes
together I think I think this this is a
couple in the making this is a match I
only like salsa dancing shoes
[Music]
foreign